this video is brought to you by magellan
tv a new documentary streaming service
founded by filmmakers who love history
their mission is to tell the great
stories that have defined the human
experience and with more than 3 000
excellent programs available on magellan
it's hard to stop once you start they've
got everything from the greeks to the
great war plus modern history
biographies scientific profiles true
crime and well so much more and their
team adds more content every single week
and what's one thing you love about paid
streaming services of course there are
no ads just great great content they've
got great playlists of content covering
both macro and micro facets of antiquity
in the roman empire including titles
like rome empire without limits so if
you already binged through all of our
playlists on rome and romans and are
looking for more content then of course
you need to give magellan a look right
now you guys can get a one month free
trial with magellan by clicking on the
link in the description below it's
content for days and days so let
magellan hook you up you'll be glad you
did and back to today's video
for most americans he's a historical
bogeyman the mexican leader who
massacred the defenders of the alamo and
then lost texas in a revolution if
people north of the border know much
more about him it's often limited to his
comeback role in the mexican-american
war or perhaps his legendary
vainglorious excesses but there was so
much more to santa anna than a footnote
role in us history far from cartoonish
villain he was a consummate political
survivor one so capable he managed to
single-handedly dominate mexican
politics for over 30 years born antonio
lopez de santa ana in the port city of
veracruz santa ana had an ability to
shapeshift like no other whether as
royalist or rebel liberal or
conservative democrat or dictator he
always found a way to not just survive
the change of political winds but thrive
the one constant in a half century of
chaos holder of the presidency no less
than 11 times this is the story of the
man who shaped mexico's destiny both for
better
and for worse
fragile winds up repeatedly becoming
president of his nation perhaps the most
surprising thing about santorana is that
he never really wanted mexico to be
independent born in zalapa near veracruz
on february 21 1794 antonio lopez de
santa anna grew up as a beneficiary of
spanish rule mexico at this time was the
vice royalty of new spain bear moth
including not just modern-day mexico but
also central america and huge chunks of
what we'd call the southwestern u.s this
was a world segregated along strict
lines one that placed the boy's family
near the top his parents were creoles
people of ethnic spanish descent who'd
been born in the new world while they
ranked below the peninsulares people
born in spain proper they did more than
okay for themselves santana's dad owned
estates and had made some money doing
business for the spanish crown they
weren't rich but they were wealthy
enough that santa ana could drop out of
school and still land a decent job with
a merchant in veracruz new spain's key
port not that it was business the boy
had his heart on but the military at the
age of 16 santa ana started pestering
his dad about joining the army despite
having served himself as pop push back
reluctant to allow his son to become a
cadet but if there was one thing
santarana was good at even age 16 it was
persuading people to let him do what he
wanted so it was that in june 1810 he
enrolled in the army of new spain if you
know anything about mexican history
you'll know that this was some
especially bad timing 1810 was when the
viceroyalty collectively lost it
just two years earlier napoleon had
deposed the board monarchy in spain in
south america this had been the trigger
for the wars of independence but new
spain had so far resisted the cry of
revolution no the key phrase there
so far at the time santorana joined the
cadets a region known as the baio was on
the cusp of exploding the silver mining
region by had been walloped by an
economic crisis and now famine despair
and resentment were its main exports it
was in this fertile soul that don miguel
hidalgo would plant the seeds of mexican
independence sadly we don't have time to
go into hidalgo today hopefully we can
give him another video all his own at
some point but just know that he was a
priest who hated poverty almost as much
as he loved the idea of splitting off
from spain on september 16 1810 he
combined these two themes into the
fabled cryolores the most famous speech
in mexican history the cry was a call
for his poverty-stricken congregation to
take up arms to overthrow the
viceroyalty far more so than napoleon
deposing the king this speech turned the
people into a republican army one that
swept across new spain but rather than
take part in mexico's independence
struggle santa anna would try to crush
it as a new recruit santa ana was placed
under the command of joaquin de
arradondo and set out to destroy the
rebels since the mexican war of
independence was a total show that
original mission soon span off into also
fighting both indian uprisings and
incursions from private adventurers
known as filibusters it was this latter
group that in 1812 saw santa ana
deployed to texas there he was
spellbound by both aradondo's brutality
and his brilliance a strategic genius
aradondo was able to pull off stuff like
the battle of medina which saw him
reduce a rebel force of 1400 to just 100
survivors by simply choosing his
defensive position well but it was what
came next that really left an impression
on the teenage soldier arredondo
followed up his victories by not just
mass executing rebels but also punishing
their families and placing whole towns
under martial law the tactics were cruel
but they were also effective it was a
military lesson the young santa anna
would never forget
as the war dragged on it began to look
like santa ana had picked his side well
after years of extremely bloody fighting
hidalgo was long dead meanwhile the
bourbon monarchy had been restored to
the spanish throne then in 1816 a brand
new viceroy was sent over from spain one
who was less like kill the rebel scum
and more like maybe we could reach some
kind of agreement yes it seemed like the
war was winding down and santa anna was
winding down with it now in his
mid-twenties he'd gone from fighting
indians to being part of a group that
helped rebuild their villages although
disciplined for misusing his unit's
funds he'd also risen up the ranks it
could have been the beginning of a long
successful career in new spain's army
had newspaper not been on the cusp of
complete collapse in 1820 a mutiny and
the spanish porter cadiz saw a new
liberal constitution forced upon the
king overnight staying under the
monarchy went from something new spain's
conservatives desperately wanted to
something about as appealing as a
hamburger made of anthrax the first to
switch sides was augustine de ituberdi
supposedly the head of the anti-rebel
forces turboday instead crossed the
lines in early 1821 joining forces with
one of the biggest rebel groups together
they marched on the capital it was at
this moment that santa ana made his
first great pivot declaring himself in
support of the rebels he took control of
veracruz bringing it over to the
republican side and he couldn't have
timed it any better as we'll repeatedly
see the genius of santa anna wasn't that
he often switched sides but that he
usually did so with impeccable timing at
the moment when his new support counted
the most seeing the growing rebellion
new spain threw in the towel
negotiations were opened and on
september the 28th mexico was declared
an independent state while not key to
victory santa ana's pivot to the rebels
was still recognized he was promoted to
general in his new role he fully
supported its erbido's post-independence
power grab
plodding as the former soldier declared
himself emperor augustine the first of
mexico but the first mexican empire was
way too unstable for santa anna to stick
on side for long as emperor augustine
was less an augustus than he was a
budding palpatine a paranoid a
repressive tyrant he shut dissolved
congress moved to set up a dictatorship
but his stupidest move came in veracruz
not liking santorana's obvious ambition
augustine seized on financial
irregularities to strip the general of
his rank unfortunately he did this just
as it was becoming clear that it
alienated all of his supporters with
impeccable timing santa anna switched
sides again declaring himself in support
of the dissolved congress in reality the
only thing he really supported was
santarana but the results were still the
same after santa aranna broke other
generals followed that winter all the
heroes of the independence war one by
one came out against augustine on march
19 1823 the first mexican emperor
resigned fleeing into exile his exit led
to the central american states jumping
ship from mexico significantly reducing
the young nation's territory but it also
led to the restoration of the republic
although he championed it at the time
santana later admitted that he had no
idea what republicanism really involved
so long as it meant he was on the
winning side though
anything was fine by him as the restored
congress began to reorganize mexico
santarana took a step back from public
life he exited the military became the
civilian governor of veracruz he married
inez garcia but if anyone assumed that
that was the end of mexico's man of
destiny
they couldn't have been more wrong santa
anna's story and his hold over this
young country was only just beginning
[Music]
the fall of augustine gave everyone an
unwelcome taste of the divisions that
would soon split mexico on one side
stood the conservatives in all their
pro-church pro-strong leader
pro-centralized state glory on the other
stood the liberals who mixed a desire
for social justice with an even bigger
desire for power to be devolved to
mexico's individual states after
augustine fled it was the liberals who
emerged triumphant writing a brand new
constitution that gave the federal
government almost no power over the
states unfortunately this coincided with
a massive economic slump unable to
effectively raise taxes the government
defaulted on its loans poverty began to
stalk the nation it was against this
dark background that the faithful
election of 1828 was held if you thought
the 2020 u.s election was divisive just
know that mexico's 1828 election makes
it look like the model of gentlemanly
conduct there were riots uprisings
disorder which lasted not just for years
but for decades from 1828 to 1855 the
mexican presidency would change hands no
less than 48 different times get to
guess which political chameleon
benefited from the chaos as the echoes
of that terrible election reverberated
across the nation santorana was finding
himself more popular than ever he was
helped in this by spain which decided
the 1828 debacle represented a golden
opportunity to land an expeditionary
force and retake the country instead
they landed at tampico only for
santarana to raise an army charged down
and single-handedly forced them to
retreat this is so heroic that grateful
mexicans christened santarana the
napoleon of the west a name he who his
characteristic ego seems to have
suggested himself yet who could really
disagree by now santa anarid helped see
off vice royalty an emperor and the
spanish navy who knew what his next step
would be actually anastasio bustamante
thoughts he might have a pretty good
idea supposedly the vice president
bustamante had overthrown his boss in
december of 1829 and was now in the
process of turning mexico into a loose
federation of states in another
augustine-style centralized dictatorship
the only problem was that each state
tended to have its own regional strong
man or caudillo none of whom were eager
to give up any power realizing the
cardios might rebel bustamante tried to
beat them to it dispatching the army to
kill santa anna sadly for him this went
about as well as ned flanders trying to
take on the incredible hulk when he got
wind of the approaching army santa ana
went on the attack driving them out of
veracruz out of his state and all the
way back to the capital in december 1832
his men marched triumphantly into mexico
city defeated bustamante fled into
temporary exile the fourth leader that
santorena had helped overthrow this time
though the man of destiny was through
with simply deposing bad governments
now he wanted to lead one antonio lopez
de santiago became mexico's eighth
president in may of 1833. his ascension
was seen as a triumph for mexico's
liberals at first it really was
santarana was a true cordillo a guy for
him having power was a lot more fun than
actually exercising it after a short
stay in the capital he put his vp the
radical liberal valentine gomez perez in
charge and he went home to veracruz to
enjoy his shiny new title but if the
liberals thought santorana's
shape-shifting days were over
they were in for a bit of a nasty shock
by 1835 farrier's radical reforms had
pissed off so many people that revolts
were breaking out rather than back his
guy though zanderana road back to mexico
city overthrew him and announced himself
the head of a new conservative
dictatorship it was a head-spinning move
a political shift so jarring it induced
whiplash
and there was worse to come the cordillo
who delivered mexico from multiple
despots was now about to become one of
the most despotic of all of them
santorina's transformation from liberal
champion to conservative tyrants was
nothing if not wholehearted imagine if
bernie sanders showed up tomorrow at a
maga rally leading chance of stop the
steal your brain just probably wouldn't
be able to grasp it right well santa
anna's pivot was that weirdness times a
million having decided that tacking
right was the only way to stay in power
the president now went all in congress
was dissolved leading liberals sent into
exile finally in late 1835 la siete de
leia saw the seven laws were published
stripping the states of their powers and
dumping them all in the hands of santa
anna for historians this is the point
when mexico's first republic ends
replaced by something called the
centralist republic for people at the
time though it was an outrage rebellions
blew up across the nation most famously
in zacatecas and of course texas in most
english language documentaries on
santorana this is where the meat of the
story lies in a detailed account of his
screw-ups in the texas revolution but
that's not what we're aiming for our
goal here is to give you a decent
overview of his entire life rather than
the bits that you've already heard in
grade school of course the downside is
that we're about to piss off a whole
bunch of texans by barely spending two
minutes on their foundational story so
sorry about all the stuff we're about to
miss out guys please feel free to
completely overreact in the comments
below not long after texas erupted
tantarana personally rode north at the
head of seven thousand men to put down
the rebellion although his army was
under-equipped things started pretty
well in february 1836 they laid siege to
a small spanish mission that the texans
had overrun known as the alamo it fell
in a bloody battle in early march one
that ended with santorana having all the
captured men executed a lesson had
learned long ago watching joachim de
arradondo do his bloody work still
tantarana wasn't all bad he let the
women children and enslaved people who'd
been at the alamo go free but this act
of clemency was just a one-off santa
rana had after all studied hard under
arendondo and he was determined to do
his old commander proud the pinnacle of
this came with the goliad massacre on
march the 27th between 350 and 425 texan
prisoners of war were murdered under
santa ana's orders despite his mexican
commanders begging him to reconsider but
this turned out to be a legendary pr
blunder the new coke of war crimes the
rage generated by the massacre go to the
texians on on april 21st they hit santa
rana with a surprise ambush yelling
remember the alamo remember goliad the
battle of san jacinto was frankly an
embarrassment for the cadilla president
captured with the threat of execution
hanging over him zandarana was forced to
pivot again from bloodthirsty dictator
to man desperate to cut a deal that deal
signed in may of 1836 declared mexico
would both withdraw all of its troops
from texas and recognize the state's
independence in return santarana would
return home alive it was hardly a great
homecoming note when santarana arrived
back in mexico his name was worse than
mud worse than manure he resigned the
presidency retired to his hatiander and
left politics seemingly for good after
all there was no way anyone could
recover from such a disaster right but
santiago wasn't just anyone he was
perhaps mexico's greatest political
survivor and all it would take to change
his fortunes would be one unhappy baker
a few years earlier mexico city had been
gripped in one of the periodic waves of
unrest that followed 1828 amid the
rioting a french pastry shop was trashed
supposedly by mexican soldiers from this
minor incident santa anna would soon
engineer a comeback so great that he'd
be able to maintain his stranglehold on
mexican politics for another 20 years
in terms of things to start a war over a
damaged pastry shop isn't exactly
invading poland but louis philippe the
first clearly didn't agree in 1838 the
french king suddenly demanded mexico pay
compensation not only to the offended
baker but to every other frenchman who'd
had property damaged in mexico too still
it was the pastry shop that stuck in
everyone's minds which is why the french
mexican conflict of 1838 has gone down
in history as the pastry war that it
helped santorana return to power was
sheer dumb luck when it came time to
invade the french fleet landed at
veracruz bamin santarana was the only
guy capable of leading the defense and
lead it he did raising an army he
charged down sent the french into
retreat and chased them all the way to
the harbor their grape shot from a
cannon mangled his left leg forcing it
to be amputated although mexico
ultimately lost the war and turned
hirana his leg the optics couldn't have
been better suddenly santa anna was no
longer the domas who lost texas but the
hero who'd sacrificed his own leg
protecting mexico it was a complete
rehabilitation so popular did santa ana
become following the pastry war that
when the presidency again became vacant
in 1841 there was only one clear
replacement santarana's transformation
from outcast to hero president
was likely his greatest change so far
yet it would also become his weirdest by
now mexico's man of destiny was firmly
buying into his own hype that inflated
ego soon led him to do some crazy ass
stuff the story of santa anna's leg
tends to be the other thing that people
know about him because it's just so bad
crazy after the pastry war the cordillo
had buried his leg at his hacienda now
he was president again he had it dug up
placed in a crystal coffin and given a
full military burial in mexico city
there was a parade cannons were fired
diplomats read speeches it was in short
vainglorious access like mexico had
never seen before yet it was a mere
taster of what was to come while
santorana's earlier presidency had been
marked by increasing centralization his
new reign aside from a brief pause when
he stepped down in 1842 was far weirder
like augustine santarana had become
fixated on the idea of mexico needing a
monarch him while he didn't quite
declare himself king he did force people
to call him his most serene highness and
started signing his letters santa anna
savior of the fatherland general of
division knight of the great cross at
the royal and distinguished spanish
order of charles iii president of the
mexican republic grand master of the
national and distinguished order of
guadalupe statues to him sprague up
across mexico city streets were renamed
after him leaders forced to empty their
coffers for his most serene highness but
just like augustine santa ana also
underestimated his country's tolerance
for a decadent monarch the last straw
came in 1844. that year sanchez's wife
died but rather than grieve the 50 year
old announced that he would get married
again
this time to a 15 year old for mexican
society
this was just too much rebellions
exploded for the tenth thousandth time
unable to raise an army sanjarana was
forced to flee the capital he was
captured by an indigenous tribe who told
the government they'd be happy to return
him as a tamale in other words cooked
and turned into snack food but the new
powers were done worrying about
santorena instead the dictator was sent
once again into exile once again so
disgraced that no one could imagine him
ever staging another comeback once again
though everybody would be proved wrong
[Music]
by now should be clear that the key to
santa ana's hold over mexico wasn't that
he was uniquely charismatic or capable
although he was certainly the former
it's that mexico in this half century
was so unstable that there was simply no
way anyone got a cordillo could hope to
hold on to power that went double when
the instability came from outside like
from say a certain northern neighbor the
election of james k polk to the white
house in 1844 would turn out to be the
most destabilizing event yet polk was
ruthlessly dedicated to expanding
america in 1845 he authorized the
annexation of texas which mexico still
laid claim to but it's really what came
next but blew things up in 1846 polk
dispatched troops to the disputed
mexican texan border considering this an
invasion a mexican unit shot at them
killing 12. in retaliation congress
declared war the outbreak of the
mexican-american war ended the
centralist republic the government
collapsed over in cuba san tyrannosaurus
chance opening a communication channel
with polk he offered to retake mexico's
presidency and settle the war on
generous terms all park had to do was
let him run the blockade and get into
his country evidently unaware of santa
ana's reputation polk agreed no sooner
had tantarana landed then he switched
sides again rustling up an army to fight
the americans it was a move which saw
his street cred shoot up but it wasn't
enough to save mexico santarana's army
was equipped with surplus from the
napoleonic era no match for american
weapons while they did win some battles
there was just no way they could win the
war mexico city fell in september of
1847. although santa ana tried to fight
on raising a guerrilla movement a hairy
american supply lines his latest
comeback was over once again he was
stripped of the presidency once again he
was sent into exile once again
it would just be temporary the treaty
the americans forced on mexico you see
was nearly as destabilizing as the
actual war mexico lost over half of its
territory unable to cope with such a
catastrophic defeat subsequent
government simply collapsed one after
the other by 1853 the nation was an
unholy mess so much so that the
conservative faction hatched a plan to
dispense with democracy altogether
turning mexico into a monarchy they just
needed someone strong in charge while
the details were ironed out just for a
year say until they could convince some
european royal to come over and be king
and can you guess who they chose on
april 20 1853 santorana returned to
power for the final time as usual he
double-crossed everybody once he was
secure he killed the plans to invite
some random royal over and instead made
himself emperor in orbit name he would
rule for life choose his successor once
again he would be called his most serene
highness but well mexicans didn't like
this any more than they had the previous
two times in the end santa ana's final
undoing was just exiling leading
liberals instead of killing them from
abroad one liberal benito juarez hatched
a plan to depose the undeclared emperor
with the help of a general in mexico he
directed an uprising that chased santa
ana from power for the billionth time
this time no one but no one expected it
to be the end surely santa ana would
come back again and again like a slash a
movie villain that can't be killed alas
once again though
everyone was wrong santorana's 1855 xr
marks the last time he ever had any
influence on mexican politics what
followed was an era dominated by benito
juarez one only broken when the
conservatives finally got their wish and
managed to install an emperor with
french help but they didn't pick santa
anna to lead their empire for the next
few decades santorana bounced around the
caribbean waiting for what he called his
inevitable chance to return he tried to
stage another comeback just after the
second mexican emperor fell only to be
tried for treason and sent back into
exile this time the state confiscated
most of his property and his serene
highness was now penniless finally in
1870 president benito juarez announced a
general amnesty for all exiles still
santorana waited until his old rival had
died before slinking back home in 1874.
by now mexico's man of destiny was old
partially deaf nearly blind forgotten by
a country that had long ago moved on
unable to make another bid for power
mexico's great survivor died alone in
poverty on june 21 1876. before the year
was out another cordial would have
seized power known as porfirio diaz he
became the dictator santa anna had
dreamed of being ruling with an iron
fist for 34 years compared to the other
larger than life figures of mexican
history santorana is today semi-obscure
a villain in texas's origin story a
funny long dead tyrant who once gave his
own leg a state funeral certainly his
impact has been smaller than that of
pofferio diaz or don miguel hidalgo or
benito juarez or well almost any other
big name his time at the top was a weird
interlude when a vain strong man managed
to fool people into thinking that he was
the mexican napoleon yet this view does
send her hana a disservice here was a
leader who is nothing if not a product
of his time an agent of chaos born from
one of the most chaotic periods the
nation ever experienced the saying goes
cometh the hour cometh the man in santa
rana for better and for worse mexico
found the perfect man
for an imperfect era
[Music]
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching